mari et femme grand-père et petit-fils
ou encore parents-enfants ses équipes de
choc sont venus s'affronter pour une
coupe pas comme les autres le trophée
esprit de famille
seule condition pour pouvoir jouer en
duo avoir un lien de parenté
quand il ya besoin de distance j'attaque
et puis et puis je compte sur mon fils
pour mettre la balle où il faut si elle
n'est pas allée là si elle a mal fini
j'aime bien jouer avec mon papa mais des
fois il y eu quelques valent donc donc
j'ai grandi un peu c'est la troisième
édition de ce tournoi certains sont
désormais des habitués
c'est un moment de complicité avec ses
enfants
donc c'est un moment surtout avec des
ados où il ya la communication et on
partage une passion commune donc ça
c'est très sympa tu vises à droite un
peu ouais 120 joueurs sont venus de
toute la france pour profiter du
prestigieux parcours de l'albatros
il ya des gens qui viennent de lyon de
marseille et ses terrains qui sont
heureux de de faire découvrir alors soit
leurs enfants ou alors de découvrir
parce que c'est la première fois qu'ils
viennent toujours joué sur l'albatros un
parcours qui accueillera l'open de
france du 4 au 7 juillet prochain